you've written in the salon Sunday today
to say the conservative party owes the
public an apology for installing list
trust as leader so would you like to
apologize yes I think we made a mistake
we do the wrong turn uh the mini budget
as I think everyone now recognizes
contained a a number of false steps I
think it was wrong to cut taxes for the
wealthiest and it was also wrong to
proceed with tax cuts without saying how
they were going to be paid for
um and to be fair Jeremy Hunters
Chancellor as soon as he was installed
made clear that those mistakes would
have to be addressed and Rishi suneck as
prime minister of course has been
Vindicated to some of the judgments that
he made during the course of the summer
during the course of the leadership
election have been shown to be correct
and Rishi now along with Jeremy and the
rest of us in government have some
difficult decisions to take but what we
must do is be honest with the British
people in order to regain trust
um talking about regetting trust is the
story in the mail on Sunday today that
Liz truss's phone and was hacked by the
Kremlin an astonishing story is it true
well I don't know the details of it and
I do know that the government takes
cyber security incredibly serious you
know if it's true or not I I said you
might not know that I I know I don't
know the full details
um and so again I I the mail on Sunday
is a trusted newspaper
um but I don't know the full details of
what security breach if any took place
what I do know is that the government
has very robust protocols in place in
order to make sure that uh individuals
are protected but also the government
security and National Security are
protected as well according to the story
they say that um the Kremlin gained
access to confidential exchanges
including about armed shipments to
Ukraine personal exchanges with the
chancellor quasi quateng and it's also
reported that there was effectively a
cover-up you know Boris Johnson and
Simon case the head of the Civil Service
agreeing to a news blackout I mean
should list trusts have come clean if
this was true well again I'm sure that
Liz both as foreign secretary and as
Prime Minister will have followed the
advice that she was given by the
intelligence and security communities
and I think all of us have to be
sensitive particularly those of us in
government to the fact that the more
that we talk in detail about these
things the more that we risk giving
information to people who wish this
country and its citizens harm so uh I'm
sure that the right protocols were
followed I'm sure that more information
as appropriate will be released I guess
some people listening might be
questioning you know if this is you know
government committed to National
Security given that Suella Braverman you
know resigned after emailing these
confidential papers from a personal
email account to someone outside a
government and also copying in the wrong
person as well a week later she was back
you know you take a week off work if
you've got the flu not if you've
committed a security breach was she seem
like I've appointed her yes we do take
security issues incredibly seriously
that's why again I have to be cautious
in responding to the point that you
understandably made about uh Liz's phone
and it's because we take them seriously
that we have uh strict protocols in
place that govern how information should
be shared and with whom it should be
shared Sue Ella is a first-rate front
rank politician she acknowledged that a
mistake had been made she is working
hard in order to ensure that our borders
can be made more secure and that
policing is more effective and she's a
valued member of the cabinet and someone
whom I admire and like uh you say that
she's an effective Frontline politician
but there are reports in the Sunday
Times today that she ignored legal
advice that the government was illegally
detaining thousands of Asylum Seekers at
manston processing center in Kent you
know this is somewhere where people are
only supposed to say for 24 hours the
support of families been there for four
weeks is that acceptable no the
situation in manston is not what it
should be but again it's important to
stress that the Home Secretary did not
ignore or dismiss legal advice the Home
Secretary was balancing a number of
different uh competing imperatives it's
absolutely vital of course that we
process people as quickly as possible
it's also important that we keep them in
conditions which are Humane but it's
like Humane now yes but it is also the
case that we're facing an unprecedented
number of people arriving here who are
smuggled into this country by criminal
gangs and the Home Secretary is focused
both on making sure that we can break
that criminal Network and also that we
can find appropriate accommodation for
people as quickly as possible it's not
appropriate is it a manston for families
to stay for four weeks there you
acknowledge that well we want people to
be inappropriate accommodation as
quickly as quickly as possible well the
situation is not perfect everyone
acknowledges that we have more than 2
000 people there at the moment but again
these are people who having come to this
country seeking Asylum when they're in
against and their Claims can be
processed more quickly and more
efficiently than was the case in the
past and in manston there are medical
personnel others who are trained in
safeguarding in order to make sure that
people are treated in a Humane and
civilized manner again uh when it comes
to finding appropriate accommodation
with them to move on to hotel or other
accommodation then that is costing a
taxpayer's significance on it's
important that we get that right and one
of the things that Sue Ella was
absolutely determined to do was to make
sure that we balance all of the
competing concerns
um I want to talk to you about leveling
up yes in 2019 you won an election on a
Manifesto that pledged to level up now
you've had three years to make progress
on that but the per person spending gap
between the North and London doubled
between 2019 and 2021 that's according
to the ippr Bloomberg did a big data
study about leveling up in June and it
found most places are going backwards 21
of constituencies in the Northwest
leveling up 31 in the Northeast only
four percent in Yorkshire nine percent
in the southwest none at all hold the
Midlands I mean why do you think you're
going to make a bigger success of it
this time than last time well the
statistics that you've um uh brought out
are uh all powerful evidence of why it's
more important than ever that we level
up of course the situation has become
more difficult partly as a result of
covert partly as a result of inflation
but we won't succeed as a country unless
we make sure that those parts of the
United Kingdom that have been less
productive uh the north Midlands the
South West are made more productive and
that requires yes investment but it also
requires much more than that it requires
giving local leaders the power to make a
difference do you acknowledge that you
haven't done enough since that big
promise in 2019 when people many of them
voted for you for the first time on that
promise we've made progress but it's not
enough you were absolutely right so we
can look at specific parts of the United
Kingdom where uh progress has been made
if we look for example at T side and the
example of Ben hatch on the mayor there
um in the time that he's been elected
we've supported him to invest in the
local economy uh whether that's teaside
airport or the new teas work site which
uh used to be the site of a steel works
now the size of one of the biggest
investments in Renewables
um in the country that is a change that
is bringing high value jobs to T side
and it's a change that's being driven by
a conservative mayor in partnership with
the conservative government our
investment zones still happening they
were a big list trusts um you know a
push I'm reviewing them so potentially
not we we need to make sure that any
change that we make is one which of
course helps to support economic growth
and good jobs for people in need but
also one of the concerns raised about
investment zones was the impact on the
environment I've been very clear and
that prime minister has been very clear
that under no circumstances will we
weaken Environmental Protections so uh I
I will be looking with the chancellor of
the exchequer with the environment
secretary and with the prime minister at
the proposals that were drawn up when
Liz was prime minister and anything that
might in any way undermine Environmental
Protections is out
um on the environment and you of course
have campaigned on green issues for many
years now but today Alex Sharma the
government's climate chainsaw has said
that Rishi sunax should go to clock 27
that's the climate change at Summit that
he says he's too busy with the Autumn
statement to attend he's also said that
the conservatives will be punished at
the election if you can row back from
the environmental focus is he right well
I think first of all Alex done an
amazing job as copper president secondly
our commitment to the environment is our
absolute and critical
um thirdly when it comes to a 10
attendance at cop I know that across
government we want to feel the strongest
possible team at cop but there are
strong pressures on the prime minister's
diary and on the pressures of others
ultimately I think when it comes to
matters environmental we'll be judged on
what we deliver
um where the fastest decarbonizing
economy in the G7 there is much more to
do and we are doing it so moving towards
electric vehicles making sure that we
invest in Renewables and also critically
making sure that we help nature to
recover both in the territory of the
United Kingdom but also in the oceans
for which we're responsible
isn't attending the cop Summit why
doesn't King Charles go well again I
think uh I I you entirely understand
um I don't want to get drawn into
details about what uh members of the
royal family will do where they should
be where they should go
um but it was clear advice from the
government wasn't it well again I don't
want to be if you forgive me um I will
avoid answering that question thank you
for being upfront about it I will be
upfront in avoiding answering that
question because I I don't want to be
drawn into something you think you
should go no no no no no I don't want to
be drawn into matters relating to uh
where the king is where he should go and
so on I just for me it's it um the
particular approach I take towards these
issues is that one shouldn't do that but
we will be Fielding the strongest
possible team at Cobb uh now I just want
to uh play a video that might be
familiar to well I'm sure it's familiar
to you but potentially to our viewers as
well it's our hustings over the summer
where Rishi sunak was filmed talking
about taking money away from deprived
inner city areas let's just have a
little watch
I managed to start changing the funding
formulas to make sure that areas like
this are getting the funding that they
deserve because we inherited a bunch of
formulas from the labor party that
shoved all the funding into deprived
urban areas uh then they you know that
needed to be undone I started the work
of undoing them
so he's talking there about on doing the
work of as he calls it shoving funding
into deprived area urban areas and I
know that you'll say look there is rural
poverty too I agree with you on that
but you know he's not talking about you
know some parts of Cornwall or
Lincolnshire where there is rural
deprivation he was talking Tunbridge
Wells that's 273rd out of 317 in the
index of deprivation is that someone
serious about leveling up yes because he
was responding directly to a question
from someone from uh fanet you'll be
aware that that part of Northeast Kent
is one of the most deprived parts of the
South East that communities in Margate
and Ramsgate even though there's been
welcome investment there recently do
face deprivation poor housing there are
a number of social ills there he was
directly addressing that point and the
Primus was made clear of course there
was deprivation in our big cities that
we need to address but there is also
Rural and Coastal deprivation which does
need to be addressed as well and
leveling up of course needs to be
focused on
um the North and the Midlands but
somewhere like thanet is definitely an
area that requires government attention
in order to improve the outcomes for
people there okay uh now you did an
interview with the financial times uh in
October this is before of course you uh
had your big uh come back if you like to
the cabinet yes you said this about
brexit I was quite interested in this
you said I asked myself all the time was
it the right thing to do I still think
that it was right but that doesn't mean
that a choice as momentous as this
doesn't require you from time to time to
think what are the downsides has it
turned out in the way you might have
imagined what lessons can you learn and
I'm I'm actually very interested to know
your answer to some of the questions you
posed you know what are the downsides do
you think well I I think it's important
to look at a big question like brexit
and to recognize that you can't make a
snap judgment a few years later and say
definitively that everything as a result
of uh leaving the European Union has
gone precisely in a perfect way I think
on balance brexit has been a significant
success for this country but I do
acknowledge that there have been
frictions and my friend uh Steve Baker
for example acknowledged that as we
resolve the situation in Northern
Ireland but some of the things that been
said and done haven't necessarily been
perfectly pitched I think that is an
example of something that we need to
address but overall I think we wouldn't
have had the vaccine rollout that was so
successful if we'd been within the
European Union and in an area for which
I was previously responsible in the
environment we wouldn't have a better
method of supporting Farmers that
strengthens the environment as well as
enhancing food production if we were in
the common agricultural policy and in my
own area there are opportunities now
that the Prime Minister was exploring to
change the way in which some of the big
funds the Pension funds invest which
will mean that more money can go into
leveling up areas those are three big
benefits of brexit you talk about the
challenges with Northern Ireland and I
think many people would agree that it's
perhaps the biggest challenge of brexit
we'll be talking about that later on the
program as well Jeffrey Donaldson of the
dep telling Sky News another election
won't break the deadlock and the UK
actually needs to focus on negotiations
with the EU over the brexit protocol is
right well we do need to focus on
negotiations
um and so Jeffrey is a friend and I
think that I would say to him and to all
the parties in Northern Ireland that
were in a strong position to deliver for
the people of Northern Ireland if all
the parties get back into the executive
that is what the Northern Ireland
secretary and the Prime Minister have
consistently said we also needed to
negotiate with the European Union in
order to find a way through and again to
be fair uh figures from Tony Blair to
those in the Irish government and indeed
those in the EU have acknowledged that
the protocol isn't working in its
current form and it needs to be fixed
was um going back to kind of your sort
of brexit thoughts was the situation in
Northern Ireland more difficult than you
expected well I certainly uh thought
that there would be uh challenges I
think one of the the issues here and I
don't want to sort of uh you know put
the blame on anyone particularly but I
do think
um in retrospect the way in which the
European Union insisted on the protocol
as a means of resolving the issues in
Northern Ireland
um the the way in which they did so was
overly legalistic
um and did and didn't take account of
the reality you signed up to the
protocol and Boris Johnson said it was a
great deal though well again the
protocol was supposed to be a sort of
living instrument
um I sat on a committee that was
explicitly designed to make sure that
the protocol worked effectively and one
of the things that I said to people in
the EU is you are trying to apply the
protocol in a way which will mean that
it will not work effectively
um and that has I mean I'm I'm not
claiming any great sort of insight
um but the the arguments that I was
putting and that Boris was putting to
the EU at the time have been Vindicated
okay now just a couple of things to
finish
um you've prepped Rishi sunak for his
first prime minister's question to
involved in that and you also of course
were involved in the pmsq's preparation
for Boris Johnson David Cameron how do
they all compare I'm fascinated well um
obviously um the public will make the
Judgment there I think that Russia did
uh brilliantly in his first preparation
yes because everyone has different ways
don't know preparing for previews I was
wondering if you know we know that Rishi
next uh quite partial to a can of Coke
did you have any particular ways of
preparing well um uh the the again
um that morning we had cabinet and then
we discussed some of the questions that
might come up a prime minister's
question time um Rishi is as you would
expect he's for me to be well briefed
but wasn't an issue that was likely to
come up uh which he didn't you know have
the full background on
um and also look this was one of the
first occasions on which the the public
was seeing him as prime minister uh the
thing that struck me is that he was
um you know cool and unflappable
beforehand
um I'm sure like football players
um every prime minister will have a
ritual immediately beforehand I know
that David Cameron used to have a cup of
tea with three or four sugars in just to
give him that extra burst
um and um I know that um when Boris was
a prime minister uh he liked to have uh
one of the the team in number 10 play
kyost armor um and so there were two
particular uh aides who at different
times played kirst armor um Rishi likes
to look at it issue by issue by issue in
a very methodical way does someone play
Kirsten for Richard Scenic as well
um there is one incredibly bright person
who ran through the questions that kirst
armor might um uh might run
um I will spare the blushes of that
person uh simply to say that she's one
of the smartest people I've ever worked
with okay uh very interesting to know
that you've had a bit of a comeback as
well haven't you were you expecting uh
to be back in cabinet no does this mean
we're going to be seeing a bit less of
you in the nightclubs yes okay thank you
very much indeed thank you thank you